what's going on guys welcome to the 25th
scikit-learn with python for machine
learning tutorial video
in this video we're going to now be
testing with the new data that we
gathered so we wanted to put together a
list
uh for training purposes of stocks that
either significantly outperformed the
market or not
and we labeled the significant
outperformers as ones
otherwise we labeled the other ones as
zeros
and we did this because our return of
companies
was just so high as far as uh
ones to invest in that our script
thought would be good
but just to reiterate we got basically
50 percent
companies saying they would outperform
and 50 underperform which
statistically lines up pretty darn good
uh so the accuracy there at predictions
might actually be very good
but anyway uh moving along we um
we want to now test and the last serious
testing script was
uh part 23 so i'm going to just copy
that
and all and paste and here we are to run
our new test and we the only thing we
need to change here is this build
data set okay because this has the new
values of underperformer outperform
so this is with any without any um
also moving on into the future we
probably could make a script i mean we
not not probably we could
make a script that does the from csv
loads this in
and then just simply modifies the
underperformer outperform or the
status right modifies the status based
on a value we set and that value is just
you know s p 500 er stock percent of
change minus s p 500
is change so we can actually modify that
really quick we don't really need to run
the whole script through like we've been
running so
uh keep that in mind so if you want to
like tweak this and maybe try
seven percent six percent six point five
percent like you can really
get to that perfect number if if you
want
so but watch out for data snooping there
uh so
with any so let me think here i forget
what we titled the
um so it's just an underscore enhanced
so underscore and enhance
um like that and you could even really
build it into this script
actually oh man so many ideas are
flowing but you could actually probably
set like a global number here
run through this and you can set the
value of the status column
uh to be a zero or one based on that
difference
uh and you do that really quick actually
so
kind of tempted to not in this one but
definitely
definitely like maybe one of these
coming tutorials i might add that up
initially this was going to be
one of the last videos but now that i
think about it that would be really
simple to add
anyway uh let's test that should be the
only change i think that we have to make
at
this point so let's run that real quick
syntax issue don't know where that
popped up from let's just get rid of
that let's try again
i should have ran this while i was
talking but yeah that idea just kind of
came to me
actually uh that we could uh fairly
easily uh thinks like maybe we got our
information not no information
apparently uh
with any let's try no n a and see what
we did wrong
uh oh we got some some suggestions there
it's strange that with n a would
have them and without would not um
we could run that maybe one more time uh
anyway so here are some suggested
or suggestions uh these would be the
companies that we
might think about investing into so this
time we only have 28 as opposed to like
the
280 that we had before so
uh there's always that uh so let's see
i mean heck even z could be the return
of
this minus this you wouldn't even need
uh or no you can make well you can make
a y
return that anyway not important
um sort of important i'm curious why
no oh see this included with not
available and let's go up here really
quick
and this is no n a uh what if we say
with
whoops uh with an a it's almost like the
mixes didn't work there
the dog's going crazy on the floor um
interesting you would expect
more results from the match
right like at least i would maybe
because it matched it didn't find
matches
i don't really know
yeah so with n a here and then you just
need this and so obviously the first
time we did no n a i think that was down
maybe here um
let's see if we got our answer yeah
still saying zero that's relatively
frustrating
and that's the length there
and then let's match no n a
with no n a up here
i mean i suppose it's possible that we
literally get zero companies to invest
in but
that kind of sounds wrong to me uh
because we have more
samples or less samples here but maybe
that's what's happening
because we are looking for a pretty
highly like a high value
um you know six percent or more out
performance so i suppose but you would
expect that
these samples are included in in these
samples but of course these have a lot
that aren't included in this and maybe
that something is
you know significantly changing our
results
but anyway uh i think in the
next video we're going to cover how
to vary the uh
performance output to decide you know
what number we want and we can actually
do that
right in the script so we're going to
cover that so stay tuned for that
if you guys have any questions or
comments on this video please feel free
to leave them below otherwise as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support and subscriptions until
next time
you